le problème ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que les réseaux en fait sans pile
c'est à dire que l'arrivée de la 5g ne
va pas remplacer la 4g ou la 3g ou la 2g
qui sont d'ailleurs toujours là
puisqu'un certain nombre d'applications
industrielles qui y sont liés donc en
fait on va rajouter un réseau ce réseau
en fait on estime qu' il
la configuration équivalent qui devrait
consommer de l'ordre de 3 fois le réseau
4g 3g 4g actuelle alors ce sont des
estimations ça dépendra en fait de la
configuration du déploiement du réseau
et des arbitrages qui peut y avoir entre
des antennes de grande portée et avec un
débit plus faible et les antennes de
petite portée avec un débit plus fort
mais voilà on va dire qu'en france ça
doit être de l'ordre de 2 et demi ou
trois fois plus et malgré tout il ya
cette efficacité énergétique et en fait
d'où vient-elle elle vient du satané
effet rebond c'est à dire que là encore
toute l'histoire de technologies montre
que à chaque fois qu'on est plus
efficace et bien en fait on consomme
plus quand même à la fin parce qu'on va
parce qu'on va utiliser plus souvent le
service
il est tout à l'heure j'ai deux vous
parliez de l'optimisation qui a été
permise au niveau du transport routier
en europe par le gps en fait et par les
applications numériques qu'ils sont
libres le taux de remplissage s'est
parfaitement vrai mais on n'a jamais eu
autant de camions sur nos routes quand
même dire que le l'amélioration du taux
de remplissage a réduit le nombre de
camions qui roulent sur les routes mais
a même augmenté pourquoi il a augmenté
parce qu'il a permis que les services de
transport soient moins chers et donc il
ya plus de trafic interurbain
il ya plus d'éloignement entre les lieux
de consommation et des lieux de
production
donc voilà on sait que la facture
énergétique c'est en france à pau est de
l'ordre de 10 térawattheures mais
milliards de kilowattheures faire pour
faire simple quelques à dire 2 2
tranches nucléaires à peu près en un
petit peu moins peut-être en équivalent
en équivalent de production
[Musique]